Finally, NVIDIA’s Neuralangelo the paper is
out. And this one is a different paper. We
will talk about this one too. Now, Neuralangelo.
This is NVIDIA’s photogrammetric neural surface
reconstruction tool. What does that
mean? It means that you can scan your
environment with your phone camera, and
out comes 3D geometry that you can use to
create a virtual world for video games, or
have a videoconference that actually takes
place in this environment. Not just
a 2D image, but actually being there.
Unfortunately, this is almost impossible.
Why is that? Well, with previous techniques,
we can choose from two different problems. One,
we get intricate details in the virtual version
of the scene, but with that, we also get holes
and other troubles. Or, if the holes are not
acceptable, that is also fine, however, then,
the fine details are gone. Now, hold on to your
papers Fellow Scholars, and have a look at the new
technique. Whoa! We can get all the high-frequency
details and no holes and no major issues appear
in the results. That is fantastic. I did not
expect the results to be this much better just
one more paper down the line. Stunning results.
The numerical comparisons here also reveal
how much ahead of its time this technique
is. Don’t forget, these previous methods are
from just one and two years ago. That is a huge
improvement across the board, especially on the
barn scene. Why is that? Presumably because here,
the high-frequency details in the
trees and the roof were completely
gone with previous technique. And
with the new one - so much better!
Now all this pairs incredibly well with our
second paper for today, MagicAvatar. Here we
can perform text to motion. And then, motion
to video. That is great, but wait a second. I
hear you asking, Doctor, this is a video, not
3D geometry. So why showcase it here? Well,
that is exactly the point! Now, if
we use Neuralangelo on this video,
we can have a real piece of 3D geometry
in our virtual worlds. How cool is that?
This way, we can spice up an
otherwise ordinary Judo video,
and even play with these
characters in a video game world.
And the magic of MagicAvatar does not
end there. You can really unleash your
creativity by using video to motion.
We get a little stick figure showing
how the AI understood our motion. Is that
valuable? Oh yes, yes it is! Now we can use
this motion to create a completely new video
with a new actor, but with our own motions.
I have a feeling that with all of these amazing
new AI papers, we are entering the world where
anything to anything will be possible. We will
be able to place ourselves in virtual worlds,
and these virtual worlds can be highly detailed
copies of the real world. Or, we will also be
able to create new worlds from scratch not just by
text to image, but by text to geometry. And these
AI-based techniques can also learn to animate
these characters, simulate how they can interact
with new kinds of objects and furniture, and they
can even learn how to simulate physics itself.
This includes fluids, fire, smoke and all kinds
of physics systems. And we will be able to meet
in a virtual version of any place on planet Earth.
Wow. I can only imagine what kind of world we’ll
be living in just two more papers down the line. I
hope you are excited too. What a time to be alive!